we can't make them a lot okay so we're
gonna have
uh uh
will perkins today uh to kick off the
talks with uh
talking about zero fear regions and
repulsive gases
okay uh thank you uh thank you all for
coming to this reunion
uh it's been really fun so far to see um
see you all again and talk about some of
the themes that have
developed since the program i'm going to
be talking about a
classical problem in statistical physics
uh
classical gases and so this is really
the original statistical physics model
uh and what i want to present is a new
result that really
came from ideas that came out of this
program
that i attended
so this is a joint work with a postdoc
at uic marcus michelin
he also actually attended the i think
the workshop on beyond randomized
rounding he spoke there
so there's some good connections okay so
what will i talk about
i want to talk about this classical
model uh and then
give some of the history and present one
really major open problem
um that is a bit out of reach
um but at least i i would like to
mention it
and then i'll talk about some of the
classical results from the 1960s on
in this field uh and also try to develop
analogies with uh
discrete models so spin systems that
people might be more familiar with
uh then i'll present this new result uh
that came from some of the ideas of the
program
uh and then at the end i'll talk about
some more manageable open problems that
are
still quite interesting but not not as
hard or maybe as exciting as this major
open problem
okay so for me some of the themes of the
program were one was the relationship
between these different
approaches to approximate counting so
markov chains
the correlation decay method and
barbanox polynomial interpolation method
um we actually saw some just this week
on
tuesday and wednesday i saw some nice
talks really about this theme and so
before the the this talk started uh khus
and i were talking that
uh really since the beginning of the
program
this area has seen a lot of development
we really do know a lot more about the
relationship
between these notions of approximate
counting um
which is quite cool to see uh and then
the other sort of more
vague and broad uh theme for me was just
the influence that different fields have
on each other so
in particular uh you know a lot of the
problems that we study in algorithms for
example maybe
come from statistical physics um
and you know combinatorics and algebraic
geometry is involved
in this program what i want to talk
about today is how some ideas from
algorithms really you can go back and
answer some questions in this
original questions that they're asking
in statistical physics
uh so that that will be the direction
today okay so here's my very vague
and broad uh view of like what is
statistical mechanics
what's the goal and i think the goal is
to be able to derive the macroscopic
properties of fluids and so here i
include all the different states so
gases liquids and solids
just from microscopic interactions can
the interactions between molecules
and then put out to a
large system can this actually uh
explain
these big phenomenon that we see and the
different states of matter
that would be very appealing if it's
true and of course this dates back a
long time so
maxwell boltzmann and gibbs in the 1800s
sort of started this this
precise way of looking at statistical
mechanics
oops um
oops okay um and then
uh many of the actual the most important
mathematical results uh
in this uh classical setting were proved
in the 1960s
so penrose ruelle leibowitz grunivald
lieb and even earlier so meyer
and um lee and yang i'll just underline
uh too so one of for me one of the
highlights of the program was
the workshop where ruel and lee gave
talks
so that was quite impressive uh that
they're still going
but they were really proving some of
these foundational results in the 1960s
that i'll i'll mention
okay so what's the rough idea of this
classical model it's that we represent a
gas
or a liquid as a collection of particles
moving in the continuum
and the the particles will interact with
each other in some way
so there's some interactions between
particles um
and as we change say the density or the
temperature
we hope to see that you know in in one
state we have
disorder that represents a gas and then
as the density
increases or the temperature decreases
maybe
a uh some long-range order emerges so on
the right we see some sort of
crystalline lattice-like structure
emerging from this
uh random collection of molecules so
that's
the vague picture um the precise model
is the following so we we
define an energy function that takes
finite point sets
uh in euclidean space so if you're a
physicist you should take d to be 3 or d
to b 2 for the rest of the talk but
a computer scientist you can take d to
be anything ten thousand
um but this energy function will spit
back a value that's a real number
positive or negative or plus infinity
um and uh the points will live in some
bounded region
lambda in euclidean space so you think
of this as a box if you like
and two parameters we have are the
activity parameter which somehow
uh affects the density and beta the
inverse temperature which will
affect the interaction strength um how
strong the interactions are
and then the model is quite simple so if
you know a poisson point process so you
have a region in euclidean space
a poisson point process is basically the
prototypical non-interacting process you
uh
in any region the number of points you
see is a poisson distribution
and in two disjoint regions the number
of points are independent
so we take a plus-on-point process but
then we
put a density against it and the density
adds the interaction
and so the density against the poisson
process is
e to the minus beta times the energy
and this adds the interaction okay um
and so this is the model so we we have
and now we have an interacting
a random point set or a point process in
our bounded region
uh capital lambda
okay and then uh that's quite a general
model because i've
allowed this energy function h basically
to be anything you want
um but i'm gonna specialize to the most
studied class of energy functions and
uh that would be a pair potential and so
now the energy function will just be the
sum
over all pairs of particles some
pairwise interaction
and this pairwise interaction maybe just
depends on the difference in
the vector difference between these
points and it can take
real values or plus infinity
um okay so if you have any questions
about the model please shout or
i have the chat open to ask in the chat
any question you have
um for the purposes of the results that
i'll present
a special case of a pair potential is a
repulsive potential
and that's where the um the pair
potential is non-negative
okay and so what this means is that
points only repulse each other
there's no attractive component because
remember this appears in the density as
exponential of minus so
phi greater than equal to zero is
repulsive
okay very good so a special case of this
model and maybe one you've heard of
before
is the hard sphere model and this was
this is my favorite model to
look at and our initial motivation when
looking at the stuff
so the potential is just the following
the potential takes a value
plus infinity if the distance between
points is less than some
number r and zero otherwise
so the only interaction is this hardcore
repulsion
two points of the point process are
forbidden from being within distance r
and so you can the point process process
actually represents the centers
of a sphere packing of balls of radius r
over two
so here we see some realization of the
hard sphere model
and this is actually literally exactly
the uh hardcore model
uh this model we've seen several times
in the workshop already
this is a hardcore model on an
uncountably infinite graph
right so the the vertices of this graph
are the points
of this region lambda and two points
have an edge between them if their
distance is less than r
so it's it's literally uh a hardcore
model on an uncountably infinite graph
okay and this particular model also is
maybe this is the original statistical
mechanics model
in terms of mathematical results about
it these were proved
back in the 1890s van der waals and
boltzmann they were interested in
something called
uh the virial coefficients uh voa
coefficients these are actually somewhat
related to the topic of the program
this is these are the coefficients of a
infinite power series for a logarithm of
a partition function
so they were already interested back
then in computing these things
there's also a nice long association
with computer science
so you may know that this metropolis
algorithm the markov chain monte carlo
method
was invented to sample from the
two-dimensional
uh case of this hard sphere model i have
a picture of
the original paper on the next page
and importantly the physicists do
believe that this exhibits a phase
transition
so from a gaseous uh disordered state to
a crystal
uh crystal state in dimension three
but uh even even on the on the level of
physics things are still
uh not completely understood so
dimension two is much more subtle than
dimension three
and um you know uh even
the best predictions even are only
about uh nine years old and i'll
i'll show you on the next slide a little
bit but these predictions actually were
driven by a new algorithm
so event chain monte carlo allowed them
to do simulations of a much much bigger
size
so there's this nice close connection
between understanding this physical
model
and algorithms
um let's see okay so here's here's just
a couple of
pictures of old papers for you so on the
on the left
is this original metropolis algorithm
paper
so a general method suitable for fast
computing machines
is described uh results for the
two-dimensional rigid sphere system have
been obtained on the
los alamos maniac and are presented here
uh so this is this is the start of the
markov chain
uh mania on the right is this much more
recent paper
uh this is the 2011 paper uh where they
described this hexadic phase transition
in two dimensions
in in uh on level of physics but you see
like to determine these properties they
were doing enormous
simulations at very high densities using
a markov chain
and maybe maybe for those of us who are
theoretically inclined
i think that the really interesting
thing about this algorithm they have for
sampling is that it's non-reversible
and somehow the non-reversibility lets
them study
uh much larger systems so
non-reversibility helps
sampling um which is kind of interesting
but those are those are some nice
pictures in their paper
okay so so back to the general setting
uh what are some basic questions about
this
classical model of a gas and so you know
the first question of course is is this
a reasonably accurate model of a fluid a
gas
liquid solid and does it actually
exhibit the same phase transitions
that real fluids do that's that's
probably the most basic question
and of course we should choose the right
pair potential
what what pair potentials are physically
realistic
so the hard sphere potential as far as i
understand this is fairly realistic or
thought to be fairly realistic
in terms of the gas solid phase
transition but maybe
not realistic as uh
as um about liquids uh something called
the leonard jones potential this is
perhaps thought to be much more
realistic i'll sketch it
it's strongly repulsive at short range
and then it becomes weakly attractive
and decaying but it's an infinite range
potential
so that's supposed to be an asymptote
this is
the leonard jones potential and so you
see there's
there's a strong repulsion the large
positive numbers at short distances
uh and then an attractive component uh a
weaker attractive component of long
distances
and so this this is the type of pair
potential that people think
are are actually is actually a realistic
model of
one of these substances
okay and then what mathematical
properties of a model like this
correspond to the different states of
matter and there's some
there's some decent answers here and
these relate to say correlation decay
so maybe in a in a gas we should expect
exponential decay of correlations
whereas
in a solid we should expect uh
long-range correlations
you can also define this in terms of
mixing times maybe your markup chains
and as mathematicians of course we can
ask can any of these
properties or results actually be proved
and you know that would be the ultimate
goal to prove that this
uh microsc this uh
model that uh just as determined by
these microscopic interactions
proved that it exhibits all these
properties that we expect
in real fluids
okay so now i i want to talk a little
bit about what has been proved
uh and you know as you know
mathematically at least in this model
phase transitions only happen
in an infinite volume limit and so what
are the basic objects
and so here now we're now we've got into
polynomials so the
we have the partition function and
what's the partition function again we
have this activity
and we have uh our region lambda capital
lambda
and so we sum over all numbers of
particles
lambda to the k so the activity is an
exponential weight divide by k factorial
and then integrate over all k tuples of
points
exponential of minus the energy
okay and from now on i'll probably
ignore the beta and just
put the beta into the potential so
that's the partition function in finite
volume
notice that if the potential has a
hard core so if there is some plus
infinity
uh interval or around zero uh then
there is some max packing and so this
sum actually is a finite sum
uh it becomes the terms become zero
after a certain
n and then we really have a polynomial
in lambda here
and the but the coefficients now are
they're not integers they're integrals
multi-dimensional integrals
okay and so to see what happens uh in
the infinite volume limit we can take a
a limit of the log partition function
take the log divide by volume
and let the size of the box tend to
infinity
uh and this defines the infinite volume
pressure or free energy
and under some mild conditions on the
potential this limit exists
uh and then we can ask for its
properties
uh and one one nice way to describe uh
or to define a phase transition is it's
a non-analytic point of this function
the pressure
uh in lambda on the positive real axis
okay so uh you can also of course define
phase transitions in terms of
uniqueness and non-uniqueness of the
infinite volume gibbs measure
but let's let's stick with this
non-analytic
point to be the definition of a phase
transition
okay so what's believed uh it's believed
that actually for a very wide class of
pair potentials they're uh they do
exhibit phase transitions and
this there's a nice survey written about
this you can look up if you're
interested
it's called the crystallization
conjecture and
it's it's even quite interesting at zero
temperature um
but the crystallization conjecture
basically says as the activity goes up
or as the temperature goes down
you should expect some symmetry breaking
so
you should expect to see actually some
lattice structure
in the typical configurations at least
in dimension three
um so that's the crystallization
conjecture
and here's the bad news uh so for the
model i've described uh a monatomic
classical gas monotonic monatomic
meaning that there's only one type of
particle
uh interacting via a pair potential
there's not a single example where we
know
of a phase that we can prove there's a
phase transition um
so that that is unfortunate um
i'll mention that there's some other
types of continuum models multi-type or
multi-body models
that have been proved to have a phase
transition the widam rollinson model
but this is a very different type of
phase transition it's like two types of
particles
that exclude each other and it's sort of
like an invasion type
phase transition where one particle
dominates so it really doesn't
correspond to this gas
solid phase transition that the model is
supposed to this classical model is
supposed to capture
and so that's that's the major problem
that i wanted to bring to your attention
uh we have this great mathematical setup
for this model it's been observed in
simulations that this really does
capture the property of real fluids
uh but mathematically we can't prove
that there's a phase transition in any
such model
um and so it would be great to revisit
this
and i mean it's truly it takes some
really
really big new ideas but i think this is
a great problem to have in the back your
mind let me just i'll give a hint
i mean this may or may not be useful but
try
dimension 24. um
so you know uh it'd be nice to prove
this in any dimension
uh but dimension 24 at least has the
um the the positive thing that we really
we know a lot more about the best sphere
packing in dimension 24.
there's this leech lattice it's a really
really good sphere packing and we can
prove a lot of
uh interesting things without so much
effort it's much easier
than for example dimension three what
about eight eight
should be easier or eight yeah good
thank you
um yeah eight and twenty four uh
those those should be the first places
to try um
exactly there's another really good
sphere packing dimension here
okay so this is this is a bit of a
bummer i would say that we can't prove
this
um but there's silver lining and so one
of the
you know one of the consequences of the
failure to prove this
is that lattice models became popular
okay so where we discretize and put
spins on lattices so easing model
hardcore model monomer dimer model
and for many of these models this
argument of piles for the easing model
can actually be used to prove the
existence of a phase transition
uh and so the silver lining is that like
somehow
discretizing actually maybe encouraged
this
uh collaboration with combinatorics and
computer science
i'm sorry but first argument it's it's a
completely different
phase transition right it's not what you
were looking for
oh yeah i it depends i might mean
completely different so you can do a
piles argument to show that the
hardcore model on z2 has a phase
transition
a phase transition meaning that the
correlation uh
yeah but but you want um an electricity
well it also means that there must be a
non-analyticity in the pressure um
is that is that right i mean for yeah in
general
yeah because yeah i mean you you can't
you
uh i mean i'll show you actually uh this
is a very classical result but
um if you have analyticity um
all the way from zero to infinity then
you have to have uniqueness as well if
you have uniqueness in a ball
okay um so that it's a it's a
it's not a it's not like a one-line
argument but uh
you can use like uh some classical
complex analysis theorems but
if you have analyticity uh in a region
containing
zero and you know that you have
uniqueness in some tiny neighborhood
around zero
then you have uniqueness all the way up
ah okay thank you
so yeah so there must be a non-analytic
point in say
the the free energy of the hardcore
model on z2
uh but you're right that it's quite
different it's it's somehow a bit
cheating because we
by putting it on this bipartite lattice
we insisted that there's only two ground
states
and and so this makes uh arguing about
the ground states much much easier um
but uh but yes so so so that
this is why perhaps uh these discrete
models uh
have have taken off while the continuum
is sort of
not studied as much now
[Music]
in fact most of the results or almost
all the results about the continuum
model just pertain to the gaseous state
so the results are about absence of
phase transition at low activity or high
temperature
and consequences of this
okay so uh here's uh here's a a really
nice paper to read
so yang and lee or li and yang in 52
wrote two papers part one and part two
about uh phase transitions part two is
maybe like one of the touchstone papers
of this program it's
about the easing model and the fact that
the the zeros
uh lie on this disc uh part one though
uh sort of sets the stage and part one
uh
proves that for and the setting is
classical continuum gases
they prove that zero free region in the
complex plane implies the absence of
phase transition
uh in terms of the non-analyticities of
the pressure
um and so this is a great paper to read
it's four pages and uh
full proofs are there they're setting
they do require a um
a hardcore so that they're working with
polynomials
but otherwise it's exactly the model
i've set up and
this really provides a connection
between complex zero-free regions and
absence of phase transition
okay and then uh so what are what
results are known so
uh realistic potentials as i
said should be strongly repulsive at
short range and weakly attractive at
long range
two definitions one is a a potential is
stable
if you take any collection of points and
sum
over pairs of sum the potential of
repairs
this should be if it's stable should be
at least minus b times
the number of points in this set for
some constant b
um and so okay so for repulsive
potentials of course
it's non-negative anyway so you can take
b to be zero but if you have an
attractive part your potential may or
may not be stable
if you're not stable if you don't
satisfy this then very often you can
have catastrophic behavior
and so infinitely many points can
condense in tiny regions
and so you actually can't even take a
thermodynamic limit
so stable is a very natural property uh
tempered
is just a way to say that the um
the long-range interaction is not too
strong so the interaction strength
decays
uh so this integral of 1 minus e to the
minus potential is finite
and this constant the temperedness
constant c phi
this will play a large role in all the
classical and new results on the model
okay so those are two definitions um let
me say that
uh if you want to read anything about
these classical models almost all the
the results and proofs are contained in
this great textbook
statistical mechanics rigorous results
and and
many of these results are still the best
known results
the one exception might be that
statisticians have studied these gibbs
point processes
um from the perspective of sampling
algorithms but otherwise
for these classical results about these
processes and absence of phase
transition this book is essentially up
to date and it's very nice to read
okay so the most general result about
absence of phase transition is
from 1963 due to penrose and ruel
independently
and their result is that for any stable
tempered potential
this infinite volume pressure is
analytic when lambda
so complex lambda is at most 1 over
uh e to the 2b plus 1 times this
temperedness constant c okay so
it's 1 over c and then in the
denominator e to the 2b plus one where b
is this stability constant
um good uh and for repulsive potentials
right b we can take b to b zero this is
just uh absolute value of lambda is at
most one over e times
c and this was proved earlier by
grenavald
okay so that's that's the classical
result and in this level of generality
uh to date uh the penrose
result is the best known so there's been
no no uh fully
general improvement to the this balance
since then
the the proofs of these theorems uh or
this theorem is by convergence of the
cluster expansion
what's the cluster expansion well this
really is the taylor series for the log
partition function
around lambda equals 0. so exactly
what we look at if we do the polynomial
interpolation method
and we want to know does this converge
absolutely as a power series
and this penrose result says yes uh if
lambdas at most uh
that bound what's interesting is and i
didn't know this before
that they proved convergence via
something called the kirkwood salzburg
equations
and showing that uh in in this region
there's a unique fixed point
uh and so um i think it would be
interesting to look
perhaps for algorithmic applications of
this method
for proving convergence
um on the other hand uh for repulsive
potentials
grunovald also showed a negative result
the cluster expansion cannot converge if
lambda's
at least one over c so it does converge
for lambda at most one over e
times c but it can't converge for one
over uh
lambda bigger than one over c um and if
you
if you you know have read this uh scott
sokol paper
uh you'll know that for repulsive
potentials
the closest singularity so the closest
complex zero
of this partition function is actually
on the negative real axis
okay so this is not physical this this
is preventing convergence of the cluster
expansion
but it doesn't actually have any
relevance to the physical question of
phase transition
and so one question is how to avoid this
how can we analyze this
uh gas without running into this problem
of the negative singularity
okay so there's there's some uh
different approaches if you just care
about positive activities of course
you can use probability uh right things
are probabilistic
with positive uh parameters and
so for the special case of hard spheres
uh there's been some progress in this
regard there's an idea of disagreement
percolation
uh that actually comes from the discrete
setting um
and in the case of hard spheres so the
for hard spheres
you know the the cluster expansion bound
gives you 1 over e
times c the disagreement percolation
bound
for hard spheres will give you something
like 1 over c
at least in large dimensions
another approach is uh markov chain
mixing
and you can look at fast mixing for some
markup chains
and this has been studied uh in quite a
few papers uh
you know there's some the grow gerund
paper is about perfect sampling
um so last year with tyler helmuth and
samantha petty we
we looked at this for hard spheres one
thing we did was we sort of uh
gen we extended this notion of
equivalence of spatial and temporal
mixing
to the continuous setting and so showed
that if you have like n log
n mixing of a certain markov chain you
get a strong spatial mixing
and we also use this idea of path
coupling with an optimized metric due to
pagoda
in the case of hardcore and i'll have a
chart comparing this to hardcore in a
second
but then we improve for hard spheres the
bound to two over c
okay so this is
uh beating the classical bound for
analyticity by factor 2e
but again this is only for hard spheres
and this really uh
all these methods really at the moment
just work for hard spheres
will can i ask a quick question yes so
this c
should i think of that as the maximum
degree in in the in the discrete setting
or is that
completely off yeah that's that's
actually a great analogy
so for hard spheres uh hard spheres this
c
is literally the excluded volume so the
volume of points that
uh if you put a center somewhere the
volume that you
exclude and this is exactly like in
hardcore it's your degree
so yes uh there's the the next uh
slide will have a nice table of
analogies but you
you've got that analogy exactly
okay so here's the analogies um so a
monatomic gas we say there's just one
type of particle so either
there can be a center present or not and
so this corresponds
analogously to like a two-spin model
presence or absence of a particle in the
discrete setting
um we've said that somehow the hard
sphere model is like the hardcore model
now we have in for the hardcore model we
have the shearer disc
like who said we should think of the
maximum degree
when do we have convergence of the
cluster expansion in terms of maximum
degrees
as delta gets large this is like 1 over
e delta
and correspondingly for a repulsive
gas we have convergence of cluster
expansion
for absolute value of lambda less than 1
over e
times c so exactly this analogy between
delta and c
anti-ferromagnetic and the discrete case
sort of is repulsive in the continuous
case
ferromagnetic on the other hand it
doesn't really have an analogy in the
continuous case because if you have a
purely
attractive potential you'll have this
catastrophe
of uh infinitely many points condensing
um another analogy is maybe a more
precise analogy
if we think of the d dimensional hard
sphere model we
we should think of like the hardcore
model on a true to the d
regular graph and in fact even more we
should think of it as
uh locally tree like because
actually in high dimensional euclidean
space somehow uh euclidean space is
almost tree-like
you can take that to mean what you want
um
let's say some other analogies path
coupling the basic path coupling
argument
for hardcore gives you something like
one over delta fast mixing
below 1 over delta you can do that very
easily for hard spheres and get 1 over c
if you do this optimized metric
technique
this dire green hill bound or the pagoda
bound you get 2 over delta
and same with hard spheres of course
this the two over delta is not the last
word
uh you know the optim somehow the
optimal bound is the whites bound
e over delta and the question that's the
real question that we had
is can you do this white's argument in
continuous
in a continuous setting um
and the answer is yes so the the main
result is
if you take a classical gas with a
repulsive tempered
pair potential then we have uniqueness
and analyticity of the pressure
for lambda less than e over c
okay so um so this beats this known
limit of cluster expansion convergence
by a factor of e
uh i think this is the first improvement
since the 60s and the general setting of
repulsive potentials
and also even for the special case of
hard spheres we get some improvement e
over two
but but that's the main result and uh
you know you should think of this e over
c as very
uh analogous to the whites bound e over
delta
um and that's that's what we're gonna
try to do
so any any questions here
okay so what would we try to do
we wanted to try to somehow adapt the
white's argument to the continuous
setting
when we were working with hard spheres
we wanted to show strong spatial mixing
um then we were told that actually like
finite range is of quite severe
restriction on potentials and people are
more interested in potentials with
infinite range
uh and so and their strong spatial
mixing becomes rather hard because you
have some
correlations at arbitrary distance just
from the potential
uh and so then we realized we we wanted
really to prove a zero freeness result
and use the
the yang li uh program um
and here there's this nice connection
that we've
uh uh heard uh this week already
but the connection between correlation
decay on the infinite tree
and zeros of the partition function so
uh the peters rex paper for hardcore
the two different papers of loose
sinclair and chubastava
and a nice paper about potential
functions and complex contractions by
shao and son
these were all very helpful to us in
trying to understand this
so what are the difficulties the main
difficulty is that the the basic
building block of this correlation decay
method is this recursion for spin
ratios of spin probabilities and
what is that could that possibly be for
continuous models
uh even more maybe mysterious is what is
an infinite tree
in the continuum and
maybe a little more mild but you know
often these zero-free arguments
go by induction on the number of
vertices of graph
how do you possibly do this if your
graph quote unquote is
uncountable so these are the the
difficulties
uh a couple tools we'll use one is that
it actually helps us a lot to work in
the multivariate settings so instead of
activity parameter being a constant now
we think of the activity as being a
function
on euclidean space okay either to
non-negative
reals or to complex numbers and now the
partition function
instead of having lambda to the k well
it's just a product of the
lambda functions over the k points
and then we need something to work with
and we can't have occupation
probabilities of course but we have
densities instead
and the density one way to define it is
it's the function
on euclidean space that when you
integrate it over a region it gives you
the expected number of points that fall
into that region
but on the next slide i'll tell you a
different definition and
one of our goals was to completely avoid
the use of probability we just want to
work with these partition functions and
densities in some setting but if we want
to work in the complex
complex parameters we really shouldn't
be using probability at all
okay so we need a connection between the
partition function and densities and a
recursion for the densities most
importantly
so here's one way to define the
densities
that can be generalized to complex
activities uh it's that the density at
x is well it's the activity at x and
then times the ratio of two
uh partition functions in the in the
denominator we just have the partition
function
and in the numerator what we're doing is
we're taking that activity function
lambda
but we're squashing down the activity
uh at points that are interacting with x
okay so you imagine if your potential is
a hard sphere potential then what you're
doing is
you're zeroing out the uh activity
in the ball of radius r around x
okay so now we just have the ratio of
two partition functions
with different activity functions and
the first is just a squashed version
of the the numerator is a squash version
of the denominator
and this definition of course works it's
just a ratio of
uh a ratio it works as long as the
denominator is not zero so we better be
careful of that
and our definition here what does what
do we want to say
we want to say an activity function is
totally zero free
if you contract point wise at all so for
every lambda prime that you can obtain
by
pointwise contraction so here alpha is a
measurable function on nuclear in space
to zero
one and so if you apply if you multiply
lambda by alpha
you get something where all the absolute
values
are just shrunk but point in the same
complex direction
we want this to be non-zero for all
lambda prime so that's totally zero free
it's some sort of hereditary zero
freeness
and what we'll eventually prove is that
if lambda of x lies in some small
neighborhood of this interval of the
real line we're interested in
then we're totally zero free
okay so two identities and you know i
don't
don't i wouldn't try to parse these uh
completely but just to give you some
flavor
uh what type of objects are we working
with since we can't do these discrete
recursions
the first identity is an identity for
the log partition function
and the lemma says uh if lambda is a
totally
zero-free activity function then you can
write the log of the partition function
as an integral
of some densities and these densities
are
with respect to some again squashed
activity function
and here we're squashing in some sort of
uh ordered way
so capital lambda of x is just a way to
say
these are the y's that appear before x
in some ordering of points
um and what you can vaguely think about
is this this is somehow like a
telescoping product
so that's one identity
um but the main the main ingredient in
this white's argument is the recursion
and so here he works with the ratios
occupation over non-occupation
probability and
on a tree to start with in his paper he
writes this nice recursion for
the ratios where rv is lambda over 1
plus and then the product
over some ratios where uh ti is
the sub tree rooted at vi the ice
neighbor
um now if you like really
squint and make things blurry you
imagine in the continuous setting well
uh the occupation probabilities are zero
but
so they're you know they're really tiny
zero is very small
so you can imagine that the ratio really
is just the same as looking at the
density
so you can forget about the dividing by
one minus
and then then you have like lambda over
one plus and then a product
of lots of very very small things
you can almost imagine that this is like
lambda times
exponential of minus something and this
minus something well
it's if you take a log uh this is like a
sum so maybe it's like
exponential minus an integral of
something okay so that's very
vaguely thing um oh if pius is asking
should the recurrence be lambda over
product one plus
uh i'm sure you are correct uh
you know much more better than me so
sure
thank you um i guess that that makes
even more sense
if we're talking about the exponential
so thank you
but here's the theorem so suppose lambda
is totally zero free and then here's the
recursion
the density at x is well the activity at
x
times the exponential of the integral
of some okay we're gonna we're gonna hit
this with the interaction but also look
at some
strange densities that again are uh
densities with respect to some squashed
activity function
and this is really like uh what we work
with all the time it's the recursion
that we'll use
but the point is that it's an integral
identity now
and good so uh and just as you would do
in the discrete case once you have this
recursion you can
use it to define a functional and now
we're thinking of this functional as
taking a
complex number lambda as an input and a
density function
rho so a function on euclidean space
and the functional is just exactly what
the recursion defines
okay and then then once you have this
set up then
then you can sort of uh do what you
would want to do in the discrete case
uh we want to prove that this is
contractive
uh you know after applying a suitable
potential function in and it is
contractive
exactly for lambda less than e over c
and actually proving as contractive is
easier than in the discrete case
somehow this has a nice form um
i mean you can imagine if rho is
constant then this is just
lambda times lambda times e to the
minus rho times c phi
okay and you know that's where you start
improving uh the
contractiveness is looking at constant
functions and so that's where the c
c comes in
okay and then contraction tells us that
if your densities and activity lie in
some
certain complex neighborhood then
applying this functional keeps you in
this neighborhood
and just as peters and rex do in their
paper
and then of course there's no induction
you can't do induction really
uh but what we do is sort of an analytic
induction we start with the
identically zero activity function which
of course is totally zero free
and we actually show that if you're in
this contractive regime
then if you're totally zero free you can
extend the region a little bit
like uh you can't actually be on the
boundary uh
and this allows us to sort of lift
the activity function from the
identically zero function
increase it increase it increase it and
prove that it's totally zero free if it
point wise lies in this neighborhood
so that's the induction sort of by
unsquashing the activity function
okay so so that's all i wanted to say
i'll uh leave you with some open
problems
i think the biggest open problem and the
most interesting one for mathematical
physicists would be that
this class of stable tempered potentials
really is the most natural class
uh and this is the you know the penrose
rouel bound uh that hasn't been improved
this includes like the leonard jones
potential uh
and really most of this the identities
go through it the question is like
how to prove it the contraction and what
to aim for
so one difficulty as opposed to discrete
cases like
i don't know actually an a priori bound
on the density
because you're you can you can put a lot
of points with
an attractive part around you and so
there's no like
obvious bound on upper bound on the
point-wise density
uh another direction to go would be can
you use this
to do some deterministic algorithms um
so
for hard spheres at least we can say
that since we get strong spatial mixing
then
uh a certain markup chain mixes fast but
it'd be nice to
come up with the right notion of
deterministic algorithm in this setting
another i mentioned was are there
algorithmic applications of this
kirkwood salzburg approach to showing
convergence of cluster expansion or zero
freeness
it's quite a quite an elegant argument
in fact
and you can see this in ruel's book um
another would be like somehow this
argument should be tight
we can we can construct a infinite
tree-like
object but is there a more natural space
where you could say
i want to do this particle this
statistical statistical mechanics model
in this random
space where this argument is tight and
where there is a phase transition so is
there a random graph analog for
continuous particle models
that's it thank you
questions
so do you also get fast mixing for mark
oh you get because of this because it's
in a in a lattice
or in like yeah exactly
euclidean space is like i guess amenable
it has polynomial growth and so
uh you can imagine the type of results
equivalence of spatial and temporal
mixing that go through for lattices
go through here
so is there any um i mean
is there is there any conceptual
obstacle to discretizing this kind of
problem so i mean you have a polynomial
finite degree so you could imagine
trying to get a sequence of polynomials
converging to it
there are partition functions of some
finite models but
yeah so there is a conceptual barrier
and that is that we actually don't know
discrete models as well as we think um
because there's
the only time we know that there's a
phase transition in a discrete model
of this type is when the number of
ground states is bounded
like it's bipartite hardcore or
tripartite hardcore
if i if i define sort of a lattice where
the number of ground states grows
with the number of vertices you know sub
exponentially
but uh then we have no idea how to prove
a phase transition
um and so yeah so you can you can phrase
the main difficulty
i think in a discrete model um
it's this bipartite is like so so strong
that it makes things a lot easier
thanks yeah really nice talk nothing